welcome to the Streamy award winning
podcast not too deep I'm your host grace
and Helbig I am just so awarding ly
proud to present this end-of-the-year
episode once again with award winning
gasps Mitchell Davis we go through our
predictions from last year's episode if
you don't remember go check it out
listen to it of what we thought 2018
would end up like turns out some of the
predictions totally spot-on
most of the predictions are about porks
and Justin Timberlake so we're also
going to go through our predictions for
2019 so enjoy our wrap-up 2018 episode
of not too deep with the one the only
award winning by default because he's on
an award-winning podcast Mitchell Davis
this episode of not too deep is brought
to you by bumblebee FF it's tough to
make new friends as an adult and that's
her bumblebee FF comes in the women
first dating app now includes a friend
finding mode - so you do is download
bumbo on iOS or Android and switch to
bumblebee FF mode within the app then
fill out a profile to let your future
besties know what you're all about
I use this actually at VidCon with
mamrie in this previous year and we got
to meet up with a bunch of you guys and
you guys got to meet up with each other
it was super super fun highly recommend
to learn more head to bumble comm slash
not too deep oh my god okay well for
everyone that's listening right now hi
welcome to the New Year Streamy award
winning podcast not too deep with me
happy belated Christmas Happy New Year
Christmas is already past I missed it
yeah well recording this currently
recording this before Halloween yeah we
haven't even gotten through Halloween
Thanksgiving let alone Christmas it
feels like Christmas yeah but we decided
to give you guys in early and by early I
mean late Christmas gift by having
Mitchell back on
mitchell davis i'm so happy thank you
for always on my spawning party Mills
hey Mitchell what do you think of the
new podcast setup what do you mean what
are you talking about have we not been
rolling we honey we have we have cameras
now we've cameras now and I also don't
allow anyone to sit on my side of the
table oh yeah it's very like it's a
weird boardroom feel it's very up I like
it I think this feels very it feels
official I feel like at the end of this
I might get a job
I like having these tabletop you might
make zip recruiter that's right no this
is our end of the year we've been doing
this for now a couple years so we do
like a wrap-up end of the year and we
thought it'd be really fun this year
because last year recorded this episode
where we made predictions for 2018 and I
remember almost none of them I remember
we made so many that I'm like blend at
what we do that yeah so we are going to
go through what all of our predictions
were over the last year and see how
accurate we might have been also again
we're recording this before Halloween so
these still have time to come true if
they're not already true let's hope okay
so actually I don't know some of these
predictions could be horrible I hope at
the end of last year I was just as like
depressed as I am right now I'm coming
in hot today yeah we are yeah you
literally feel feverish jack you've got
to stop touching my soaking wet he keeps
touching my head in like a few nickels
you're free everybody's got
big old case of them Oh guys don't make
it weird I need ad brought to you by
head nickels
okay sorry everybody we already did that
yeah Jax here any time I've only just
reset well yeah come on I'm gonna make
it so that it's just the old show every
time Streamy and all of a sudden you're
like I've gotten very good at coasting
and pretending and listening we're just
waiting for the silence and then now me
talk that Wayne's rolled up a movie I
forget that whole joke commit to it go
for it do the intro thing where they're
trying to talk about this in Wayne's
role to where he's telling everything on
the radio thing of the guys like oh yeah
great uh-huh uh-huh and then by the time
they're at the end he's just like your
sphincter and you're not listening and
he's like oh yeah that sounds great
wait gamble okay speaking of things that
we have committed to if you are some of
our opinions and predictions of 2018
from last year yeah as of the
award-winning history me nominated and
winning podcast not too deep okay so our
first category was we predicted what the
state of YouTube would be oh god 2018
what did I feel do you want to know what
you said okay oh yeah this is profound
and thoughtful YouTube becoming so your
prediction was that YouTube would become
more of a social media site less of a
quote upload site a hub where you stay
and chat mm-hmm you know that's right
and wrong yep we're doing reading gonna
have to throw the shades back on oh look
at all these looks you're serving this
episode yeah I mean how would you how do
you feel about that I mean that I hear
that there's a community tab on YouTube
in which you can like stay and chat I
don't take advantage of it obviously I
was gonna say I've if anything I'm like
look I got to get out here as quick as
possible now well it's partly right in
that you know people still do upload
it's just that people don't see your
uploads
clapping we can put stuff your
subscribers then don't see them yeah so
it's a way that's how that works just
like nagging you yeah yeah so we're
kinda we were kind you like half right
on yeah grace your prediction was
YouTube is gonna become more of a news 2
based platform I think that's very true
you know I mean I think in there's
certainly more duck you'd docu-series
rock you dramas dramas duck you Syria
really news though I feel like no it's
not yeah not really it's just like no
it's not news but I feel like to fill
the Franco's I'm gonna become like a
even more legitimate news based kind of
like hub I'm just gonna go ahead say I
can't find a [ __ ] reliable news
source anywhere let alone just YouTube I
just can't news in general all of it I'm
like I don't know if it's true anymore
you know what you should just be a so
listener of the Streamy Award winning
just get all your news right here we
have our food away vote for you want to
know anything about the real Real
Housewives oh that's the only news I
care about making a murder - I started
last night wait don't okay so stream it
it's on a streaming platform like a
bonus episode after we watched the
season two I would I would love that
I need liked it even more cuz also like
five episodes and I'm like morning just
from today why heart just wet like I
didn't know that it was out and I was
just I wasn't really makeup I was being
a little [ __ ] so she woke me up really
and then she went directly back to sleep
I was like you [ __ ] so I was left by
myself and I was like what's a boy to do
and so I was like well watch making a
murderer to make a murderer part two and
again yeah it's just oh okay well let's
let's table this for now and then come
back to it maybe in an episode that's
solely for discussion on making a murder
- if you guys would like to hear
something like that or watch something
like that of course let us know okay
Jack your prediction for YouTube is
YouTube is transitioning curious to see
what it'll turn into that's named in a
prediction that's just a what that's
just a thought I was
that's a guy who's just like you know
what I'm not sure even what a YouTube is
like make a prediction I don't know I
think it might be more you guys skipped
me a lot because when there's a lot of
these kind of Diane wrote these oh wow a
lot of categories are just as Jack na I
mean it wasn't coming in hot you know
yeah that's true and I still think that
like I do think it's accurate I think
YouTube is continuing to be a platform
in transition I don't think anybody
understands what's going on I feel like
it's also one of those things where it's
like you know how there's this like that
myth that like you know like half of the
Coca Cola recipe is in one vault and the
other half is that's not a melt
I don't know this at all okay this idea
that like the Coca Cola recipe is so
valuable that they like no one can see
the full recipe because whatever the
value is okay there's a similar thing
going on with the YouTube and like
Google algorithm no one has ever seen
the entire algorithm they can only see
their little specific chunks of it
people their design Apple runs though
they don't notice that means they don't
understand how it's fun no there's no
single person at the company who's
looking at it on a holistic level being
like wait we're no no wonder our videos
aren't ending up in people's subscriber
boxes no one's looking at the actual
tech that's I mean I think that's the
reason why everything's so I use a lot
of like I mean I think there's a lot of
transition like behind the scenes at
like YouTube as a company itself I mean
as far as I know my like points of
contact there are always like rotating
so I thought you know we're kind of
coming and going so there's not real
sustainability in the works very high
turnover yeah so I wonder how that
trickles down and obviously effects like
this consistently mythological algorithm
that we're all supposed to figure out at
some point I think you're just supposed
to break yourself online in front of
everybody if you were being printed yeah
people keep using a word algorithm and
I'm like I think it's a randomized thing
yeah is that sex robot from Bojack
horseman the boss the sex robot boss
he's just running around Google being
like I'm coming
and everyone's like okay I guess if he's
coming were coming so we just gotta keep
coming I really think it's just a huge
accident at Google like there's someone
in a corner who's like oh yeah yeah
there's like a ferret on a laptop that's
just pushing but the algorithm feel like
that makes more sense yeah I want to
believe that versus someone
scientifically logistically sitting down
and be like this will work just a room
of ferrets with glasses in front of
laptops oh here's a okay our predictions
were the first thing that you would
think of when you think 2018 YouTube Oh
Mitchell's prediction was the Rock's
channel will be the most subscribed man
that I wish that had come true you know
did show up though and kind of sweep it
up okay god bless love what he's doing
but like come on man you're great at
everything just give us you to tell you
to no I want him to take it I want to
really take care and then I want him to
be like I got a collab with these kids I
want him to get into the shane dawson
therapy docu-series thing and come to my
house and talk me off a ledge and get me
back in my youtube game I just want to
kiss a prediction for 2019 I see him do
crazy things and then him showing his
family who we've kind of always thought
were these like kind of unreal humans
yes you know like they wouldn't
understand anything and like their
vacation video his vacation video where
you get to see Jaden and just the family
every acting normal but also being like
a little weird well Smith is my dad
don't it's he's still [ __ ] he's still
a dad I love it it's The Fresh Prince of
bel-air but he's like he's a lame dad
sometimes he's yeah he's got that energy
yes it does have dad energy I'll never
use that again Vicky I feel like it's a
category on pornhub you made it weird
you double down on making it weird
please don't do that on the Streamy
award winning way we keep dropping the
fact that we want to Streamy because we
just came from this we didn't drop it
picked it directly yeah so I'm just I
just it feels a little because this is
coming out in December ace is holding
the Streamy under the table
oh yeah it's I let go of it okay I
predicted that Liza Coe she would be the
President of the United States oh yes a
true dream I know you just took over
double there
yeah which is basically what the US
looks like to the rest of the world you
try and [ __ ] knows that people are
shoving their arms and trying to pull
flags out I just I just love that
Nickelodeon that they were like you know
what what's the grossest [ __ ] game we
ever had oh also what's the most OCD
hosts that we can get to pair up what
station back on - can we encourage his
fears and like bring them back up all
these years the way that you might have
been like actually doing well let's put
it right back in there yeah PTSD that
guy yeah I loved him when he talked
about candy though do you guys remember
that no okay [ __ ] it it was like diners
drive-ins and dives views like I want to
teach you how to it's your old are made
and it was so [ __ ] I gotta check that
out okay to do Marc summers
Jack you predicted that the rise of
musically stars or some new app
generation of youtubers why was I wrong
about that I don't know they musically
kind of I don't I haven't got usually
not seen a tick tock ad it's very now
yeah in October now we're talking yeah
we'll see how long that lasts but I feel
like this has been a year of no like you
know the latest ones and Hannah
stockings whatever yeah that's all the
vine the vine people and are fully
committing to like full digital
powerhouse they're doing commentary
videos that are like 29 minutes long and
[ __ ] that's what the algorithm supports
long videos award-winning podcasts not
too deep it's now putting out an hour
long videos on my youtube channel give
this a round of applause this is a ward
winning this is a ward winning everybody
thank you Jack [ __ ] hated that joke
so much it's like
God every time his he was like I'm gonna
kill this but there's all these like
really big right now are these channels
that are like that are like starting
stirring the YouTube drama like the
drama behind the scenes yeah I don't
know like I did not predict that that
would become such a phenomenon so I
thought it's like you know the e
entertainments the extras the disease of
the like traditional entertainment world
that it only makes sense that gossip
channels are gonna start flourishing and
you on YouTube the same with like the
docu-series stuff like it only makes
sense that people are now having burnout
and like going through like their
decade-long like what am i doing phase
thats never happened before' Mitchell
Davis this is you to burnout there's a
picture of me it's a mug shot rebranded
I was like full burnout it's a mug shot
from when you robbed the bank
but I thought I yeah I I guess I thought
that that would happen more and more I
feel like TMZ has been a big like kind
of proponent of that yeah you know I
guess I don't know I just for so long
YouTube just felt like this place we're
like you had to be very upbeat and
positive and now it's like it feels like
it's all about you can get the team yeah
you could ship a little tea now actually
I [ __ ] hate that person yeah well
that's and that was surprising to me
because for so long it was so positive
and now I feel and like in fact if you
brought negativity to you sort of like
you were like it was like looked down
upon yeah I know I know exact in the day
early days when you were the person who
was like kind of given other youtubers a
hard time I mean you were just like
[ __ ] shunned you were gone yeah yeah
it was a very like safe space in terms
of like support and community I mean the
idea of community in like the most like
basic pure supportive sense isn't
necessarily there anymore it's like a
business infrastructure now rather than
like just a bunch of random like
creative weirdos trying to do something
fun and supporting each other high tides
raise all ships now it's like
competition yeah cuz this like okay this
it's cratering so I'm gonna get as much
as I can
yeah
screw the rest of you yeah I also think
there's been like a huge one I like it
lots of fun yeah mental health it's
become a real proponent and like the way
we all operate there I think more than
ever this year it's been like more of it
that'd discussion that's been a good
thing in my opinion yeah fact that we're
sort of I think leading the charge was
like real conversations about like where
we're all at breaking the stigma yeah oh
literally a ghost just turned off the
light in this house and I felt something
on the back of my back it touched me I
probably have five scratches on my back
I felt that oh man we're gonna need to
get the ghost adventure guys back in
here this is you're listening and I know
you are we've got we've got a ghost
adventure for you in this house thank
you okay my back is bleeding bad another
prediction and I'll tell you what's
wrong with it
okay so last year we predicted the next
quote style of YouTube videos what's the
hot [ __ ] to watch you and Mitchell you
predicted oh well you didn't even
predict that dang it
you weren't even your own fan last year
you predicted digital newspaper coming
back I don't even know what that means
digital newspaper coming back digital
newspaper coming back I can guarantee
you I was high and thought that that was
genius like just hearing you say that I
go that's a thought that I've written
down and been like that's genius and
then the next day been like what does
that mean right and then also clearly
neither one of us were listening to you
because it didn't seem like we stopped
you from giving us that opinion I like
the Diane wrote it and wrote it first on
the list yeah neither one of us
questions I got of course digital
newspaper coming back yes not just
digital news the propositional news
never coming back you know what when was
it here to begin well maybe I just met
digital news you are trying to blog you
know what mainly I'm just trying to make
it make sense yeah but I think that's
just a high thought that's little craps
that's why I'm in the floor yeah no no
not at all yeah you seem you got time
you seemed very uh that's why you so
sweaty reminded really you could wait
not not smoking most make you sweaty
I don't know I wasn't sure your
award-winning I thought maybe you have
all the answers grace your prediction
was will see more david dobrik styles
stephen sceptic sugar pine seven style
reality TV style produced scenarios no
actually disappeared a little bit it has
but the david dobrik style i think is
still more prevalent and i will go so
far to Pat myself on the back because
the reality TV stuff is like the shane
dawson docu-series stuff that's
happening I will say David Oberg though
it's it's it's molding it's growing into
a lot more of a craziness of like a show
than it was a yeah there's a full cast
yeah and there's no children involved a
little yeah there's like a whole show
it's a show now oh yeah that kid that's
in his vlogs was living his goddamn best
life at the stream is he was on his
chair screaming the whole time
yeah he's having a great time I felt
like if we didn't walk onstage with a
dog or a child we were not participating
in Internet that night you also
predicted that well you just said you
were excited for Casey nice that's news
platform excited to see the fool tell us
about it grace how was it be more three
six eight if you blink you missed it as
far as I know I don't know you know what
no shade looks three six eight three
hundred sixty eight days a year no wife
just had a baby he took a little bit of
a break I think it's gonna be a merge
thing I don't [ __ ] know CNN bought
one of his apps he's fine yeah they
bought it closed it down like a couple
months later he's doing well that's not
worried about where's broken sunglasses
for fun yeah yeah you guys Ray Bans
which I could never even get myself to
invest in and [ __ ] him up for fun he's
like let me teach you how to [ __ ] these
up properly because this is unique okay
just a lot of those you said more
blending of fiction and real just in
line with what we were talking about
I think that's a david dobrik thing of
like creating a narrative that is also
you know and also i'd reality you guys
heard about lonely girl
this [ __ ] is blowing my mind well about
lonely girl issues the actress or the
character wait what wait you're telling
me it's faking that you just burped on
an award-winning podcast yeah keeping it
real oh my gosh two things that just
blew my mind yes sorry buddy that was a
character she was playing oh god okay
our predictions um what would break the
Internet in 2018 Mitchell [ __ ] did you
say you said lots of marriages Justin
Bieber Selena Gomez had gotten back
together Britney Spears Justin
Timberlake quote finally you were so
high this episode I really wasn't this
is honestly a thing that just look
Justin Timberlake and Britney Spears in
my heart forever are just in a denim
outfit yeah they are in love together
walking on the pitch and there's a
unicorn next to them and it's white and
neither of them are on it but it just
just follows them I don't think you were
so off because I think the thing that
did break the internet what the thing
that broke the Internet this year I
think was the Ariana Grande it's in the
sagas episode airs
they could be fully married with kids he
can have all of his taxes covered up I
know right yeah it's but it is I think
about that like why is that so
fascinating to me because it is I'm
genuinely curious about it and I you
know I I like pop culture normally but
for whatever reason I'm like insanely
fascinated by their relationship they
cannot figure out why I just appreciate
cuz on SNL he's like he's so transparent
like I mean when he goes on Weekend
Update he always goes on is Pete Davison
he doesn't do a character and that like
ariana grande like gave him some good
clouds I love it I mean there was a
whole episode once where he was like
talking weird and then like I even
remember before he left he's like sorry
got my teeth fixed got a lisp now and I
was just like wow that is such a real
thing to do because like you know when
you get a little bit of money and you
start changing things you know you you
most of the time you try to sneak it by
people and he's just like look at my new
[ __ ] teeth man
yes I just loved it I thought it was so
I thought it was cute my buddy my buddy
max Silvestri was on a podcast talking
about there's an award-winning pocket it
wasn't not don't name it but he was a
podcast talking about this and he was
like he's like that relationship was
doomed
he's like once everybody in the public
is talking about your dick yeah he's
like that's just way too much scrutiny
started that whole thing I mean yeah
they started it with like probably
nothing but pure love for each other and
then all eyes get on your relationship
becomes a meme meme now I mean people
are still I'm still waiting for the
Twitter moment that tells me they're
back together every morning I check
what's not happening more marriages know
now he's probably take a break oh we're
just [ __ ] stop for a second okay I'm
just worried I'm just worried camera
shot in the back Jesus you guys that's
my phone bye listen this is why I'm not
on the podcast anymore it's really hard
to produce well be on the podcast here
we go it's a real awkward segue into a
[ __ ] ads Akbari we'll be right back
whatever the [ __ ] like producing us this
week supporting us thank you [ __ ]
jack he's always here you know
Mitchell's gonna be 12 times sweaty or
we get I'm actually cooling off I feel
like I'm cooling off
[Music]
this episode of not too deepers birthday
by Zola Zola is reinventing the wedding
planning and registry experience to make
the happiest moment in couple's lives
even happier combined and compassionate
customer service with modern tools and
technology all in the service of love
Zola is the easiest way to plan your
wedding and register with free wedding
websites your dream wedding registry
affordable save the dates and
invitations and easy to use planning
tools start with a free wedding website
it takes just minutes to set up and you
can choose from over 100 beautiful
designs that fit any style and every
type of wedding
put your Zola registry on your wedding
website so guests can get all the
details that need and buy your wedding
gift all in one convenient space the
Zola store has the widest selection of
gifts at all different price points from
over 500 brands there's something for
every gift sorry every guest to give can
you believe that to start your free
wedding website and get $50 off your
registry go to Zola dot-com slash grace
that Z o L a.com slash grace to get $50
off your registry today this episode of
not too deep is brought you by classpass
it's a fitness membership that gives you
access to over 10,000 studios and gyms
around the world try any workout from
bootcamp to Pilates to yoga and more all
bookable with one easy-to-use app they
take the barriers out of working out you
don't need to plan a circuit or do
anything just book a class and show up
class pass holds you accountable sign up
for a class with your friends so you're
less likely to quit class pass is more
than just working your muscles when you
try new kinds of workouts you increase
dopamine and boost memory formation and
they drive results when you work out
with a trainer you get a more effective
workout which will help you get fitter
or hit your goals faster and they're
motivating because you're always working
out with the best trainers in the biz
it's a really fun way to re-engage with
old hobbies like swimming climbing
tennis and more Jack swears by class
pass and I'm always looking for a way to
push myself out of my comfort zone and
this is a
great way to do it you might find out
about classes you didn't even know
existed
underwater yoga pilates who knows check
it out there's so many options there and
it's super super easy to use you can
start your free trial at class pass calm
slash try slash grace that's class pass
calm slash try slash grace okay I
predicted what would break the internet
this year is that T Swift was gonna be
pregnant which could still happen but
still happen this to happen I mean she
likely she birthed a beautiful tour of a
show she's also been voting predicted
that III definite neither III kind of a
political yeah political beliefs on
anyone should just encouraged education
what's cool is this episode's gonna come
out after the election so you need to
drive me fully you gotta drive me to the
polls I'll Drive you to the I'll get you
an uber the polls yeah yeah well okay
you heard it here first
Jackie Mitchell we're going voting again
no you can get an absentee ballot to
minus future people are happier because
the election went well remember us as we
are now yeah I know okay Jack your
prediction was not applicable yeah see
you guys railroaded me just going off
about Justin Timberlake and Britney
Spears get the same passion about that
thing I could totally imagine I just
steamrolled it yeah you're right
okay predictions of who is gonna release
the most fire mixtape Mitchell listed
everyone Mitchell basically I bet you
talk for twenty minutes and we just let
you go Kanye West has lost his goddamn
mind yes well that was your prediction
with Kanye West Frank Ocean chase the
rapper Frank hasn't put out anything he
said 2008 this isn't fair I think I
mentioned chance the rapper is like just
you said throwback comeback Justin
Timberlake I think you were just like
Justin Timberlake kick might have just
know this was just lingering JT love
from the last question yeah and then you
said miss Elia did she release a new
she didn't really send you out if she's
an exception hopping on a few songs
honestly everyone I named there I really
wish would have put out something long
and extended hmm and instead I just got
really the one that you were obsessed
with the most actually produced it
wasn't I just wasn't it what yeah it
wasn't a good album it wasn't the album
that I was looking for honestly yeah I
mean NEVER well it's why we didn't talk
about it that much well no the music
video of like the AI robots that he's
like sexually dancing with I was a
little confused by a lot of people did I
think people tried to push it deep down
in their thoughts so they didn't have to
think about because it was like he was
doing like a fake Steve Jobs but at the
end he was a robot too and then he was
also just like err [ __ ] a bunch of I
was like this TED talk went weird and it
made me uncomfortable I now see why I
forgot all of it grace your prediction
was P Diddy is on the verge of putting
out some fresh and new content fingers
still cry happen I feel like he will but
it'll be like a commercial for like a
company that sells like pills for your
bones like P Diddy zaas does vitamin
water fish oil pills in 2019 you owe me
a million dollars or you can only play
it if you buy the fish it's like a
little USB you got to put the fish oil
we're having new ideas Jack your answer
was not applicable
[Applause]
okay let's talk about the biggest Mima
predictions Mitchell you said Kanye West
wow I was right and you said he will
have resurfaced and people will be
obsessed with what he posts online it's
quote gonna be his year and he's gonna
be quote throwing out a lot of
positivity that people will eat up some
people he loved from his perspective
we're going so if you have you dislike
totally disowned him now look it's I am
still very much like an I can separate
an artist from their music I really love
his music but his actions right now they
are automatic
they are problematic in there they're
honestly just something that I can't
stand next to Stan I can't stand next to
ya I'm having some sort of people
listening to me because I don't want
them to think that that's how I think
right right right
I will never look him wearing that red
hat is so [ __ ] stupid yes I am and me
saying that is crazy you'd like I'm like
dunking on you but it's just like I
can't but if he's so like that's how you
know how actually problematic that he is
that he's forced you to have a public
political opinion yeah so anything if
this is some weird [ __ ] like mind
trick to get all of us to vote by
supporting this piece of [ __ ] that's an
office right now playing 4d chess no
he's playing he's playing checkers by
himself what's your what's your feeling
on that though the whole like separating
the artists from their art kind of thing
cuz you can still enjoy his music even
though yeah you completely disagree with
what he's saying politically yeah
there's a lot of that going on right now
or it's sort of like how do I am not
allowed to enjoy this Woody Allen movie
now well that's a different that's it's
very different I mean I know but but I
mean but but I I think that's an
interesting question I think we have to
ask because I think there's a lot of
people that are like oh you can't watch
China now now Roman Polanski I'm like
yeah that is I understand what you're
saying but like I'm able to understand
that he can be a problematic human being
but still enjoy okay okay here's here's
how I always break it down is what
I'm an artist every piece of art that I
make doesn't have all of me in it it
doesn't contain every aspect of and
everything I believe it was that moment
what I was trying to stylize and get and
create and make and that's awesome and
if it if it represents something bad
that I can just [ __ ] clearly see like
transparent like if Kanye's next album
is make America great again I'm gonna
[ __ ] hate it yeah that makes sense
see but see what I'm saying like that's
what I mean where it's like there were
like like you're saying with old movies
these movies are made so long ago and
they were made in it they were just they
were made not with anything like that in
mind yeah and I mean it's it's when they
get to closes when you got to go nope
sorry no but I think it's interesting
because like you know we still listen to
Michael Jackson see but I think that's
why people are still kind of creeped
about Louie CK is it's just it's too
close to what he joked about it was too
real it wasn't no there's no effort
outwardly on his part of remorse regret
growth yeah he didn't halogen apologize
there's no problem it's a public
understanding that he knows what he did
was wrong but so there's a like you
could still house of pushing aside
pretending that that part isn't
important or it isn't a valid thing to
acknowledge and just going but look just
laugh at me you're like no no no no I
don't know I don't disagree I don't
think there was any harm in him just
being like this was a mistake and I'm
sorry and I don't know why he just
hasn't done that like he's come out with
statements but none of them were just
like this was a mistake and I'm sorry
it's it's straight but I yeah I don't
know why that's so difficult for people
to do because maniacs like that that get
off on jerking off in front of women are
gonna have a [ __ ] skewed perspective
on what they should do and how humble
they should be and how to treat but a
human being even when they even looked
like the Cavanagh confirmation hearings
were going on I was like man if he just
came out was just like look I've done
some I've done some crappy things that I
don't even remember because I used to
get too drunk in high school all right
there and if I if I hurt if I hurt this
woman I don't remember it doing it but I
did I'm really sorry I was like why
couldn't you just take that perspective
instead of being like I am being
attacked because it's be
so much - what kind of character he is
yeah I know yes he's the bad guy in
pee-wee Herman I want that make that
face I was like I've seen his face
before and then I thought a pee-wee
Herman and I was like when he gives him
that gum and he's like I was like that's
a grand about Trump - same kind of
trauma see today's Biff from Back to the
Future yeah yeah that's trusty III try
to relay everyone back to like evil
villains and movies and movies well my
contribution to this conversation is the
same as my prediction for a biggest meme
not applicable well Jack you predicted
Bella Thorne on the verge of turning
into a meme hour possibly due to a
breakdown or identity crisis from her
Disney branding which kind of happened
yeah she's fully like Tana conned out
and it's like embrace this like very you
know that's quite a meme per se but
she's just becoming she's definitely an
internet thing she's doing a little bit
of the Miley Cyrus like I'm this is I'm
going full other end of the spectrum
from my like you pretty controlled
branding yeah
and I'm hoping she doesn't go completely
off the deep end because if she's
actually pretty smart
I was just one interview it's really
great and it gives you a fuller
perspective because I did what a lot of
people did like judge her based on these
small snippets of her world that I see
on social media I mean I watched that I
was like that's it's a much he sadly she
gets crazy
follow her on anything and I hear about
her all the time
reason I mean she knows how to get her
name out there does like Tana they're
really you know getting it done doing
that ok catchphrase got raised a year
hmm Mitchell you thought it was gonna be
that's all folks I stand by it
exclamation a question mark box dang it
and then you joked about the fucked-up
eye on iPhones after the episode with
that
you guys watch a marriage in the candle
season too though yeah where that they
play and they play that as part of it
where he's like you can tell though
because the eye is a box and like
there's a whole episode where they're
trying to figure out whose phone it was
yeah yeah yeah that was a big deal I
stand by it the bank for Mitch oh that's
cool
grace your prediction was meat meat I
mean technically Internet is getting
faster it's a very Road Runner yeah I
mean I think they're just on a big
Looney Tunes kick that's where our
predictions Jack your prediction was not
applicable if you could yeah if you
could catch phrase it now if you're if
you had to come up with a catchphrase
for 2008 rates for now forget for 2018
it will be this oh god now what what is
it now what actually would it have been
what do you think the catchphrase was
this year I think my I mean it's still
time but gosh I think mine would have
been like I think I'm gonna unfollow
them
I think I'm gonna unfollow them yeah
perfect
okay new emojis are predictions for new
emojis Mitchell you said sexy time
facial expression what does that mean
like a facial expression that means
let's get it on oh you listening to the
podcast you're gonna want to tune in to
Grace's change see that face
I have to use this mic stop kissing stop
kissing and like deep throating or am i
exaggerating we lost all of our
advertisers in two seconds
speaking of grace your prediction was
there's going to be a boner emoji yeah I
don't think it's gonna go over well guys
we got a really weird new emoji actually
well I feel weird even using what is it
it's the one that's going
but his head's like way too tilted back
I don't know I'm looking at I look up
that every time I see that emoji it
doesn't say it doesn't say I'm saying a
telling you a secret it says I've killed
someone you don't know no it's just a
little circle it's just a little circle
guy and he's just kind of half eyes open
just I don't know he's a creep I mean oh
it's like fully about the murder yeah
that's it chapter two is gonna start
with that other screen is just Kid Rock
a full fever dream right now your
prediction was common phrases and emails
that was your prediction for emojis I
don't know wait I don't know what that I
think Jack turn into a printer this
question but you that mean it phrases it
emojis in emails like they have the
autofill now creepy that did happen yeah
it is really really good yeah it's too
accurate so much you don't give you a
full sentence that's like your verb ate
like everything but also like I'll just
start with the letter I and then it
fills in everything I don't think I can
make it I'm actually not feeling too
well I'm kind of sick and I don't think
I'd like [ __ ] knows everything so
far how far before we see that
technology just like write your essay
for you for school just talk this book
was oh it's done print great yeah
because I mean I mean eventually there's
only so much history so they're just
yeah computer once a computer gets it
Jack wow I'm gonna have to go through
school again and get better grades 2019
okay our predictions for the new
character we're gonna fall in love with
in 2018 Mitchell's was Star Wars Fox
made of ice you were high know that in
the Star Wars trailer they had just
dropped the last Jedi there was this
scene where you saw these little foxy
kind of animal
and they were made of ice and I was like
people porks in them people are gonna
love even though you're wrong about both
production with Star Wars porks yeah I
think they had a moment see you know
what happened was is the movie was no
good I mean I'm just gonna be out there
was just so many things about that movie
cuz I mean these those foxes they kind
of play the big role in the end and you
know what I still don't care still
minions I think people are still into
minion Rick shrek won't die and I [ __ ]
love it it's just every every time I
look somewhere I'm like god damn it is
another [ __ ] off-brand shrek I love it
well though that's the minions are
really like my vision board for just
longevity of brand and I feel like
they've done a really good job a single
word like keeping overalls alive for so
long they just say banana right that's
all they do I have no idea I know
nothing about them no they bother me
yeah and they weren't even like the main
point of the movie they were just like
the little sidekick care yeah I think
they're the smartest stupidest [ __ ] I
think we're just jealous your prediction
was not applicable I fell in love with
not having an opinion okay what everyone
loves now but everyone will hate by the
end of 2018
mm-hm here are our predictions you said
Mitchell the fashion VEVO and Facebook
yes yes and yes you [ __ ] nailed it
and we hate it's gone it doesn't even
doesn't even isn't even know I think it
still exists I don't know anything about
this okay we got everything everyone
hates Facebook no even people who are
like when we're like doing that's just
like that we love people Shane
accounting well I mean people I think
they liked it at first because they were
like I'm gonna have a proper VEVO
account that makes me a real musician
and knowing we're in a year later where
everyone goes oh that doesn't make any
[ __ ] difference that just means
people now takes a chunk of it know that
that makes sense
the fashion I hate fashion right now
- fashion right now me and Jack go to
the mall it's so funny cuz I'm showing
him the new cool stuff and he's like oh
my god it's the ugly it's just like
logos on top of logos and these chunky
Balenciaga everyone's look like an extra
in an episode of Seinfeld it's so I'm
over the obsession with Gucci like the
news like the weird branding that's
going on right now weird like kind of
ironic but also genuine like obsession
with buying like Gucci slides and things
like that I don't understand that at all
I don't either
yeah I know exactly it's a brands are
it's like for a while there it was like
oh it's tacit of a brand now it's like
there's just giant champion logo on your
t-shirt yeah it's like that cost $350
well to be fair you as a frugal Queen
growing up I used to go to Ross Dress
for Less and buy only name-brand stuff
but the logos were cut out because it
was like $13.99 though I really was
trying to project what I really wanted
to maybe this is just some you know
childhood issues coming back to late can
I give a prediction for this coming year
well I keep all your opinions your
prediction was not applicable yeah I
think I really got sleepy by the end of
this prediction was the iPhone which I'm
not I don't think I'm totally wrong
about it but they feel ambivalent about
oh this is no this is the first iPhone
that came out where everyone was just
like yeah and I think there's like so
many but hey there's a lot of people who
are even like like unboxing videos
people like I'm watching and they're
just like it's cool but like you don't
see the pixels going [ __ ] nuts well
the camera yeah it's all about the
camera now literally all you need is a
decent camera and people are gonna scoop
it up and also I can't I got it I hate
dongles guys I'm gonna say it they don't
even give them out anymore doesn't even
come with the phony mister they're just
like fully committing to this no dongle
life dongle right now what all right
okay ere are our predictions for the
general trends okay I personally had no
opinion on this apparently not
applicable
Mitchell you said VR porn Oh you also
said Steve Zaragoza for yes let's hang
out soon let's hang out oh this is just
a person so just me talking to Steve and
you know what his number so you use the
podcast as a way to reach him and we did
we did hang out and you know what I will
say also Steve Zaragoza the valley folk
but that became a general trend that was
a thing yeah they launched they're doing
it and also VRA are I mean that's so
that's so in a are for sure I think VR
is kind of in a what's a are augmented
reality that's where like you can like
use your phone yeah mine is way off jack
you in a very serious your prediction
for the general trend of 2018 was a
return to decency after a year of out
seing the creeps of Hollywood yeah so
wrong couldn't be more wrong it was only
the lubricant to find more what hey
robots are they gonna kill us these are
our predictions if robots were gonna
kill us
oh I said amazon treasure truck truck
isn't coming near this recording so she
can get some [ __ ] our Xbox guys don't
know amazon treasure truck not spawn
fingers one day like an ice cream truck
of Amazon products they'll tell you that
it's a in a certain neighborhood and you
can go to it and get stuff items are
like on the treasure truck they'll be
like bad Santa's coming yeah okay your
prediction on if robots are gonna kill
us was cool robot dog bull robot dog
what does that mean I was honestly I
know never he was stone no you
really hitting me no Brooke a cool robot
dog is actually something that sits in
my mind fur it's been years and it is
the fact that I've always wanted a cool
robot dog I've always wanted a dog that
was a robot okay that just kind of was a
little fun dog okay but then when he
pooped it was like nickels and like so
you just want money no I'm sorry no
nickels but like like like screws and
bolts I don't know that seems more
annoying than a normal dog just telling
you [ __ ] robot are they gonna kill us my
thought is no I hope I get a robotic dog
okay you an optimistic yes again I would
walk it I would have fun we would I
would treat him as if he was just a
normal day basically you use the tail
end of last year's podcast to just ask
for the things you wanted to hang out
with so there goes together manifesting
and we just let you go yes you said you
were no answering everybody just let me
do it I fully like fell into this Jack
you said you were hopeful that we will
start seeing Amazon drone delivery BOTS
yeah I'm still haven't gotten those
things yeah but we going I think you
combine those two ideas and have a
delivery dog robot dude I'm have you
guys seen the post mates like little
tanks little boys make tanks yeah if
your thing is in proxy and the store has
it there it's just like a little I don't
know it's like a cooler with wheels and
it just they just put the food in there
and it just like slow rolls to your
house look Mel's freaking out all right
this I don't like this at all hive
sounds like a Star Wars droid and yeah
yeah if they're close it's there and I
don't like I saw somebody literally
tried it like they did a whole news
coverage thing where they were like
we're gonna try to break into one of
these things and it just makes the
craziest noise and they're so heavy how
embarrassing it was awesome well okay
here's hoping for next year that's
terrifying
okay personal resolutions Jack and I
have no answer for this black race and
Jack not applicable
cuz I'm sure
Mitchell you just went off you all say
your personal resolutions for 2018 where
more tattoos in it more animals no
popcorn hell yeah that's so [ __ ]
crazy isn't that I bet neither of you
said anything I said that I and that
much not much of this came true did you
get more tattoos yes do you have more
animals no popcorn
I mean you're the majority of that is
true and to be fair I could have just
been talking about the food I love a
good popcorn name yeah I think you were
just going for it and we were just
waiting for you to be done yes this is
one of those times we were just like is
Mitchell [ __ ] still talking was
amazing
unmute is Mike whenever it's ready Wow
well we really we really predicted the
[ __ ] out of 2018 Wow where we ever
spot-on guys I was really proud of us
for a very accurate prediction don't be
freaked out I know what you're thinking
no we don't time-travel no no we just
happen to know and we're gonna take a
break and after that we're gonna predict
what's gonna happen in 2019 yes I'm
gonna go get a my DeLorean rock walk
don't like that creepy tone it's a samar
get with it the prediction that we fully
overlooked cardi B did it has some more
video did you see it that's the most
internet sentence I've ever sort of not
too deep is brought to you by ever Lane
and never overpay for quality clothes
with ever Lane they make premium
essentials using the finest materials
and without traditional markups and they
tell you their real cost because they
want you to know what you're paying for
and why in fact they are so radically
transparent about everything from their
materials to the ethical factories they
work with and since they sell directly
to you their prices are 30 to 50% lower
than traditional retailers their clothes
look better cost less and last longer
they've all kinds of simple stylish
clothes made from super quality
materials I'm talking cashmere cruse box
cut tees silk shirts high-rise skinny
jeans mid-rise jeans boyfriend jeans day
heel
stay flat anything you want they have it
no frills just quality and right now you
can check out the personalized
collections that both Jack and I put
together of items that we have hand
selected for ourselves from the website
go to every Lange comm slash Grace and
you'll get free shipping on your first
order that's everything comm slash grace
every Lane comm slash grace okay
now we're on to our 2019 project
predictions yeah starting tomorrow it'll
be 2019 do you listen to this um again
like we said we're recording this in
October so a lot of these things might
be completely off the mark but I have
fractions in general are fraught I have
faith I feel like we did a decent job
last year we can do better this I think
we can beat I think we can beat our
average from last year yeah just by
answering questions let me go first I'm
just going to say that because clearly I
influenced some stuff and my stupidity
was there that's all folks and you went
meat meat okay here we go the state of
YouTube yeah for 2019 predictions okay
coming in real simple the state of
YouTube for 2019 I think hmm I think I
was gonna be a return to like long-form
narratives mm-hmm I think with the
docu-series stuff there's like that's
reality I think there's gonna be
long-form scripted content on people's
channels Oh like almost like movies I
hope yeah I think there's gonna be a
huge drop-off of just creators in
general on YouTube oh yeah I think
there's gonna be lots of breakdowns I
think I don't think like a meltdown
they're already starting to get in the
middle of it please support me on my
patreon
please God I'm a hundred people away but
uh yeah I I think that there's gonna be
a huge trouble people realizing that
this is just not for me anymore yeah
yeah that's a breaks I think there's
gonna break no I don't think it's gonna
break I think it's gonna be someone
literally going I'm I'm not doing this
I'm leaving this as an archive you can
enjoy it this is not my resume yeah I I
think people are gonna phrase it frame
it that way but I think people are gonna
be too scared to leave completely
I mean I'll say I honestly say I'm gonna
leave completely all the time and I know
that's time like I'm going off your
track record and I never I'm never gonna
leave because everyone was like [ __ ] I
found that nose pretty cool lot of
people taking breaks and figuring it out
but I think they're going to quit the
idea that they're like this was my show
yeah like I'm making five videos a week
I think they're gonna just be like I
might show up every once in a while yeah
you know he's doing that really well
wheezy waiter Craig yeah he didn't like
freak out he just stepped back any
chance I'm right after he had that huge
video and he just keeps [ __ ] yeah and
then he just puts out not the a like the
one month without sugar and then he just
did another why exercise is no fun and
like yeah it was like one-offs
he's clearly working on themselves
behind the scenes but they're using it
to sprinkle into his entertainment
yeah it's good okay my prediction
actually III wish what you predict is
will come true but I don't think so I
think we're actually going to see much
more controversy I think we're gonna see
no more drama more drama more people
just sipping tea just seriously I like
that phrase because it sounds so lame
we're just like overly simplifying like
you know we're just like being mean to
each other
yeah and I think but unfortunately I
think that's the thing that gets clicks
and I think that's going to continue and
it's going especially culture especially
with you know these documentaries you
know exposing this and excusing that I
think people just gonna be like okay
well I need to get in on this action
yeah positivity is is no longer in vogue
we have to it's mystery it's like a
mystery click now you're not sure it's
actually real or if it's going to get
that yeah you know what thumbnails kill
now is when it's just one person by
themselves looking sad
and the title is just a word like help
or you or and then in parentheses not
clickbait yeah something like that where
it's just like but those you're right
look at ik emotion if I saw that in the
next dude it was just like a hundred
percent movie you'll love I'm like I'm
still gonna click this ya know as much
as I don't like I contribute to that
culture yeah okay what's gonna break the
internet in 2018 2019 brother Mitchell
Jack yes are you guys gonna get engaged
2019 what I think is gonna break the
internet honestly I think it's gonna
have something to do with I think Barack
Obama's gonna make a YouTube channel
I gotta start vlogging well he does have
that like Netflix deal doesn't he yeah
he's got he's about to get a whole
station he's got a whole slate of show
so much correct yeah mmm that's that's I
we're not talking just YouTube we're
saying Internet yeah you know yeah the
thing that's got like like how the Kim
Kardashian photo broke the internet like
what's that would that be the big
splashy thing that just I think we might
see in light of like all of the you know
behind-the-scenes drama of like oh I
didn't realize that person was a creep I
feel like we're gonna see one that's
gonna be really really really big and
maybe from someone that was I very
trusted yeah yeah and I think it'll be
and it'll be like OJ Simpson level where
we'll be like everybody is going like
it'll either be somebody who's like not
only was he a secret creep but he was
also a secret murderer or something oh
dang interesting okay that's my start
sorry
no I also think that that's the thing
that people are drawn to like yeah it's
like whenever I'm on Twitter and I see a
celebrity's name the first thing as I go
what happened they they either got
caught doing something terrible where
they died yeah I'm both terribly
negative things yeah it used to be that
way and I think that yeah you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna say it's gonna be
something Kanye West's gonna do I think
he's gonna come back to the Internet in
some insanely dumb grand fashion he's
gonna run for office and people are oh
he already announces press
see but I think your president I think
he's literally gonna like out Mike Pence
and like run with Donald Trump I I just
it hurts my heart but like that is a
possibility in my brain he just keep
here's the only reasonable way that you
can it has nothing to your talking he
just keeps putting out weird little
websites that are like single-serve
ideas that he has okay and then they're
like and I I've noticed that he's doing
on Squarespace
probably use offer code grace he would
actually be someone that would be
listening oddly to this website that's
called like the united states of love
calm and it's just like everything I've
ever made free here now or something
insane I don't know I could just see all
of the internet just being like and now
we've yeah he's because he's one of
those weird people that just like can
keep coming back he keeps coming back
and he can also heat he can kind of
orchestrate the show even if it's an
idiot show I mean he can dress up as a
water bottle and we're all like [ __ ]
cool that's cool now and it's not just
like he's the most the most professional
troll it really is just a professional
troll yep like I could see like the like
boopity scoop on like a ten times level
yeah but he's skewed I mean if that's
the beginning like what's about to come
then yet next year's gonna be [ __ ]
weird okay your prediction break the
Internet no that's gonna break the
Internet well I I think okay what do we
who's gonna release the most fire
mixtape I'm gonna add on to this
who is gonna release or get exposed for
an unfortunate sex tape there's going to
be a massive iCloud security breach
without us needing or wanting it is
going to be exposed with an unfortunate
sex an unfortunate sex tape well Donald
Trump uh isn't that sexy tape the P
tapes that come out that Dave's probably
gonna sit
that's one I don't ever notice a
receipts forever I just feel like it's
it's just so close to the internet like
it's I don't know what do you think one
of the Avengers Oh what gonna be one of
the Avengers that's wait which one I
don't I don't know Robert Downey jr.
more like Chris Hemsworth encouraged
what if it was hidden camera and you
just see Thor just start making out with
a hawk or something you're like wait
what not happening and then just he
slowly turns back into Bruce Banner
needs like you a beautiful that's my
prediction my prediction is that Mark
Ruffalo is going to spoil yet another
Avengers okay
mixtape wise I think it's gonna be Jaden
Smith oh yeah that's actually very
reason I think it's gonna be Jaden Smith
or I think it's going to be tired of the
Creator I think chance the rapper
I think chance the rapper is a great
contender yeah I think it's been a
second yeah it has I feel like he's got
stuff brewing yeah I get I mean it's
Frank Ocean I always want to do it I
hope please a personal yes who's someone
that hasn't put out something in a
minute that I would be like yes run the
jewels Celine Dion go okay so you're
you're kind of reaching in the end of
the you know what maybe they had that
amazing song that came out like last
year whatever with DJ shadow Celine Dion
P Diddy collaborate out there I think
it's possible
fingers crossed I will start to GoFundMe
for it
get it going unfortunate mixtape I also
hmm okay unfortunate I mean unfortunate
sex table of the unfortunate sex tape
yeah that's right
The Avengers Sally Jessy Raphael okay
it's gonna be unfortunate would be
unfortunate is the president Oh No the
current the Trumper talking about
traffic cone that's an office right now
okay biggest meme 20 and 19 biggest me
so I actually think that memes
personally I think memes are going to
get more insane and make less sense I
think we're really like are you living
in 2011 I mean that's the definition of
a meme I think they're getting more
specific really I think memes are
getting more specific but they also
they're I feel like their timelines
their shelf lives are so small now they
live and die in like 24 hours yeah I
know yeah so that's why I think they're
gonna get even more absurd where they're
like these don't even make sense I feel
like like it's gonna be like every meme
is gonna feel like an episode of Tim and
Eric oh god I can't wait you're looking
for I you know here's my peers my actual
prediction I think a lot of prediction I
think a lot of people when they want to
normally post a meme they're now gonna
post themselves doing the thing that the
meme like a challenge well like the way
that there's like the the faces like the
emoji faces that you can do now an emoji
so yeah an emoji is where I think
instead of like a face getting sick and
a person doing something it's like
you'll just film yourself doing it and
then you're an emoji will be that you
know I'm saying like they'll say [ __ ]
finding it I'll just I have a storage of
my emojis I think there's gonna be some
version of the Walmart yodel boy but
it's gonna be like frog in a Kmart or
something plays the harp they're just
iterations of old memes but kind of
different I just keep wishing every year
that IKEA monkey would come back and so
I think maybe and I were very close to
flying ourselves overseas to shoot a
video at the IKEA Monkey paying out of
pocket that's incredible
yeah we were really really close to
doing okay speaking of memes though I
will say I was on reddit yesterday and
someone was saying the future of memes
are 3d and it's the guy holding the
girl's hand looking at the other girl oh
yeah here's what's great so it's 3d now
so it starts to turn and then you it
just
on the back it just says but okay
because he's clearly staring at her ass
and so it was just saying like it was
just like lamely saying like we can show
you the back of images now Oh like we
can 3d render like it was people it was
rendered out it was so weird it was so
weird yeah I think that those okay my
new meme prediction is that that the
three people in that stock photo are
gonna release a song they're gonna
release the most fire mixtape their sex
tape is gonna get released that one me
more he's like oh sorry baby I was just
look corns gonna include memes like porn
is gonna do general I think porn is porn
is becoming more normal like it's
becoming part of like just talk about
culture I think it's just like I think
poor means exactly as what like yes it
yes agreed
Vegas ma'am Jack what was yours uh
biggest meme yeah but we're talking
about I don't know I already said this I
said that I think memes are gonna get
insane predictions that they're just
gonna get crazier yeah okay catchphrase
of 2019 oh gosh yeah that's about sums
it up it's not mine would be like what
did you expect you're out here living in
2018 or 2019 2019 yep yep that's it oh
geez new emojis for 2019 this one I have
a friend who is very upset there's no
red head emoji there's no men and women
Oh
Ginger's got at me coming that's line
that's gotta be next I think okay okay
you know I want to see more spooky
emojis spooky yeah like we've got that
one ghost goes that's pretty much it
like I always aam be
I won't break in stein like the whole
Warner brother yeah what to see all the
mummies and all that stuff okay yeah I
haven't fully checked in on where the
emoji world is that right now they stood
so vast now remember when it was just a
couple pages and now it's like they're
like people are bitching about the
[ __ ] bagel not having cream cheese
it's not I think there's gonna be more
food I think there's gonna be more food
more drinks I think there's gonna be
more sentiment safe bet condom is a
doubling down on condiments there's no
ketchup now I don't think so or mustard
mayonnaise
give me some relish I bet this guy's
crazy things what are they thinking Oh
family portrait yeah there's gonna be
more family peiser it's gonna be a lot
more ink like inclusivity it's not the
right word you're wrong people like
inclusive yeah okay family me the idea
of like nuclear family is gonna be
completely broadened on me oh I mean on
emojis emojis yeah that makes sense
yeah yeah that's my prediction okay new
character we're gonna fall in love with
in 2019 I guess this was movie person
just someone who's not not real
character yeah the way that you guys
went off on pork oh [ __ ] what's everyone
gonna lose their mind about on 29th so
they feel like this year it's all been
reprisal movies like franchise stuff
it's not even TV shows like magnum p.i
is bad yeah this might get a little bit
that it's not no longer about like the
big box office celebrity like a lister
like a Will Smith that comes into a
movie it's more about the franchise and
it coming back so it's like I think
that's gonna continue in 2019 but with
that the character that I think we're
gonna fall in love with hmm I think it's
gonna be Adam driver who what the actor
as a character but because his character
as kylo Ren no I just meant like his
work [ __ ] it I you know what
for next year that Mitchell just went
off on Adam driver at the 20 minutes
it's going to be bumble baby oh yeah
they're gonna make like a Lifetime movie
about the trajectory of this
award-winning podcast thing now now that
not too deep is an award-winning podcast
creamy award-winning pocket can you
believe it I think no [ __ ] I think I
think that we're gonna we're gonna get
start getting offers for spin-offs and
that's gonna end the bumble baby movie
is going to be huge as Macaulay Culkin
doesn't play the bumble baby in the
movie about not too deep you really
upset well okay you're an executive
producer so I'm sure we can manifest yes
okay I think hmm
I think that I almost almost grabbed my
phone to start looking through people on
this is bothering me
I'm very character also be like you know
a nonhuman character I was thinking like
the Hamburger Helper a little gloves
should I make a big comeback in Crash
Bandicoot
okay video game really fair see him
coming to make a comeback uh-huh yeah I
would like to see the the mask mask yeah
okay what everyone loves now but they're
gonna hate by the end of 2019 oh my gosh
go on gentle exclamation no oh my god
he's already freaking out about it is
Jim Carrey playing the Sonic the bad guy
in Sonic the Hedgehog knuckles or
something I don't know the name Oh also
what's-his-face
playing mr. Rogers Oh Tom come hang also
Woody Harrelson playing carnage
we're just naming things we've heard of
on the Internet yeah and I bet you while
you're gonna freak out about all those
things okay sorry I had to get that out
oh and maybe the new Grinch okay I gotta
stop that new Grinch does look good yeah
it blows me out that there's no Jim in
it but also the old Jim was like was 14
years old 12
yeah okay thing that everyone loves
right now gonna hate in 2019 I don't
think they're going to hate it
necessarily but I do think we're going
to start seeing a backlash on weed
marijuana marijuana yeah grass yeah I
think we're gonna start seeing because
it for so long it's been like this thing
like the other way we're gonna be like
wait a minute
I think we're all smoking too much weed
no I agree I think there's gonna be a
thing where it's all it's like a bit
about backlash yeah now that
everything's here and we're all gonna be
like and now I'm gonna go there with
nothing with just my mind and people are
gonna love that autocorrect
I think everyone's gonna hate I already
am bothered by it yeah I like you can
disable it though
you can I think it's like things like
that that provide like an ease in like
efficiency in using your digital
technology I think people are gonna be
like I don't like this it's the way that
like Alexa's and people are like freaked
out about like government listening and
stuff like that which they are I think
there's gonna be like a huge backlash on
all of that we talked about how like the
Gmail is just writing itself yeah I
think people really go back to like
maybe like straight-up traditional
phones things like that just a
typewriter send a thank-you note
give me something tangible there you go
that's what you think
what was the question what people like
they're gonna hate the campaign hate in
29 by the end yeah by the end maybe gosh
I don't know this is there's a lot of
things that I feel are in the same shade
house serious you take all these
questions I almost want to say Apple I
feel like you're wrong I don't think
you're wrong I feel like it's going to
be car already sliding yeah I feel like
it's just becoming another one mixed I
feel like I've seen maybe this is just
because of my friends work with the
brands like the pixel that there's like
so much promotion for those kind of
products that I'm like I feel like
people are swinging that way when Apple
is still trying to play the luxurious
card right and yeah the thing is is
that's just not hitting right now
everybody is into like you know
courts where and like they want it they
want things that are athleisure
yes athleisure and they want colors and
things like that they don't want this
like just like $2,000 gold rim yeah yeah
may we drop them constantly and like the
glass cases and things like that
I can't I mean for what reason this is
the first iPhone where I'm not like
crazy
I'm not excited to like I'll get if I
need to but I don't like like how do I
get it like if this breaks I will get
the new one but it's not rationalizing
why I should get it right now okay
general trends kind of touched on this a
little bit mm-hmm but what do we think
general trends of 29 this is um it's a
mental health awareness self-care and
I'm gonna go ahead and say the thing
that before I forget from earlier which
was I think it's going to be fashion is
gonna take a turn where it's not about a
big brands it's actually all about small
brands it's gonna be about you're right
it's gonna be about wearing a shirt with
a logo that no one actually knows what
that is
yeah I think that's gonna be there's
this small company it's called wavy - no
no seriously check it out
no but I mean like I think though like
those types of things you might be right
you know who are making where just for
specific specific audiences yeah and
they're going I think that's gonna be
the new big thing and and I also think
it's gonna be one of the things that
kills out like you're saying the Gucci
that yeah that trend of let's recreate
the same thing over and over again no
let's all make something totally [ __ ]
different yeah I can see that for sure
yeah and in order all being reasonably
priced hmm okay I'm gonna be optimistic
for a change
I think that I'm hoping again this is
going to come in after election day that
there is a record turnout among young
people yeah and as a result of that
politicians are gonna start catering to
the wants and desires of young people
addressing things like you know how are
we going to guarantee the people aren't
going to go bankrupt if they get sick
and how they're gonna pay their student
loans and things like that and I think
they're gonna have to start listening to
us and people that are younger than me
because we're finally voting and with
such force that they can't ignore us
anymore
yeah I think there's gonna be a huge
wave of activism yes like this is I'm 33
years old but I feel like this is the
first year I've ever like
educated myself on politics and they
actually took any initiative to o be
engaged with what's going on or you know
my license just so I could vote yes I
mean turn on CNN now ms and we see like
all these things that I had never ever
done before as an adult so and I feel
like that's hugely due in part to like
all these very young you know parkland
survivors and activist inspiration
amazing so intelligent and so engaged
and encouraging and like over time you
know it's not like want it done I think
there's gonna be a longer sense of of
people getting involved yeah and so Lee
so it's not all doom and gloom I do
think that as is going to start
happening yeah finally you know what I
would almost like to say that I will
just broaden going even further I think
just education in general just knowledge
and being sharing it in general is just
gonna be a bigger thing into that I
think it's gonna be really cool to get
informed yeah I think of all time like a
trend for people to be in the know and
having candid conversations about things
yeah I think it was cool to be ignorant
for a while yeah kinda just be like
whatever you know I'm just doing my own
thing and now it's like no we have to
come together
I hope it's embarrassing for people who
don't vote oh people that don't oh I
agree have a sense of shame rather than
before it people didn't vote because
they were sick whatever my vote doesn't
matter that those are sense a lack of or
an erasing of apathy yeah I I sweetie
look the other day I was like it's not
enough to vote you have to shame your
peers and devoting helps like culture as
a whole but I think it's important yeah
telling everybody there will be socially
unacceptable you're not participating in
a or just embarrass their ear in this
watch that we're running and without
just one piece the [ __ ] watch doesn't
work yeah and that's I keep trying to
tell myself that this like okay Mitchell
even if you're the smallest little gear
that makes no [ __ ] anything not even
a noise still needs to happen you're
part of it because without that gear
doesn't [ __ ] work I'm with you
speaking of that robots are they gonna
kill us in 2019 uh have I told you guys
about my robot dog obsession moving on
personal resolution
I don't need to talk about the robot dog
personal resolution would poop like
screws he's so adorable I mean yeah that
week you okay
personal resolution and named him socket
oh my god I'm in charge me about to cut
you off like Bicentennial man okay sorry
like my personal resolution waiting mmm
I would like to be able to speak decent
Spanish conversational Spanish by the
end of 29 I'm learning now I'm using
like doing stuff oh no no say like a
sentence como estas
hey I think please listen to not too
deep I don't know how to say that
[Music]
hopefully I'll be I'll be able to say
that very well by the end oh wait oh wow
so we're next year don't let us forget
we've got a challenge yeah no that's
good now I've got a stone if you want to
sponsor lingo I've been using duolingo
and actually okay what's your resolution
I think creatively is to get my groove
back a little bit give myself permission
to like experiment with some stuff I
love doing this podcast so I'm glad like
we have a video portion of it now which
is really fun to put on the YouTube
channel I think provides a new like
angle that's really fun and like flushes
out the show there's two of them
actually yeah Oh doing only two angles
so I think I want to get back into
getting excited to put myself out there
creatively without oh really analyzing
like how I create stuff that's a good
one that's good I think that's a HAP
like a trend that's happening in like
the Creator community as a whole image I
know like we've talked a little bit
about it yeah I feel like it's kind of
just kind of in the air I mean yeah I
mean I shouldn't be able to like say yes
and freefall
creatively like I felt like I did like
in 2010 again and see what happens
yeah Mitchell personal resolution
personal resume [ __ ] robot dog
solution no I think my personal
resolution is honestly I just want to
just [ __ ] make stuff I just want to
keep making things yeah I feel like I
haven't made enough things and I just
feel like I need to make more things I
don't know that's good it's just it's
very basic but I just feel like that's
that's what's good
that's what's brewing in my head and
also I would just love some money I
would love to make some money yeah
that's fair yeah there you go
I think that's all very are working on
some things together so we go cominis
got some got some we got the big twins
over here giving a proclamation of I
don't know what well I don't want to
jinx it
yeah yeah but we're trying to make sense
well all positive vibes I think that's
kind of like our overall mission here to
obviously to grow this show to over the
next year and see what happens I know we
want to do some like live stuff we're
not just resting on our stream you guys
yeah I mean now that we're an
award-winning podcast we have to compete
with other Award winners but also you
know not many podcasts haven't worn yeah
we do yeah I saw your tweet where you
were like I can't believe everyone hears
all the other ones and I was like well
today I also got I got defensive gonna
saw someone being like views deserves it
they have no downloads blah blah blah
and I was like fair but please take a
listen to the back I thought it was very
sweet to use you Apple did oh yeah I did
it out of spite generous because I was
feeling petty yes thank you dear friend
for being on another episode of nuts to
transformer outside I'm sorry
trash guys emptying our trays here make
sure we don't talk about his sex tape do
I have something to show you
oh gosh well thanks Mitchell this has
been fun and guys will have to wait
another year to see how all these
predictions pan out let us know what
your predictions might be oh right you
get a fortune cookie
I forgot oh yeah I got a fortune cookie
you got a fortune cookie for being a
guest on the episode I keep it at a
weird distance open it hardest fortune
cookie I've ever you just fully like
Gallagher smash that like a watermelon
this is a long fortune the winning
lottery numbers are 529 1908 I can't say
no read that's fortune you've done this
a million times
it says the winning lottery numbers are
529 nineteen ninety four ninety three
and 77 Wow we didn't say when but like
probably at some point somewhere so
you're welcome over in Korea now like
what if she's got some juju and that's
like correct you might she might be 529
nineteen ninety four ninety three and
the Powerball seventy seven man I wash
that with my grandparents every night
and I [ __ ] loved it and for years I
did not understand what the numbers were
for but I was just like this is a crazy
show happens for three seconds am I in
my dream packs before the news and my
grandparents make sure to watch it and
I'm just like oh my god it's a it's a
woman just playing in a bucket of balls
and numbers I what isn't happen I just
wanted the machines I want to be the
girl that pushes the buttons and makes
the balls come up and I always remember
I would get so excited when two would
come up and she was like not just the
one on inch you have to cut that one off
and you'd see sit down I tried to
predict it oh right before I make 1704
early just sit in front of the
television and in my grandpa and I would
just be like 14 it was 12 it was nine
don't just play your birthday too deep
toady toady not too deep as a production
of grace Helbig incorporated a producer
and directed by Jack ferry producer and
editor
Melissa demons writing by Diane King
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]